[Music]
okay everyone I'm so excited today
because I am joined by Navia B and Tom
Wright who star in Daisy Jones and the
six on Prime video how you guys doing
today I'm good good I'm so excited to
talk to you guys I love the show I love
your performances in it you bring these
characters to life and it's I'm excited
to see for people to see you guys do
this and nabia you being a singer in
real life is it strange singing as
Simone as somebody else is that like
something that you have to adjust to
particular song for you that it sounded
a lot a lot like me and we did a lot of
work to make sure that Simone sounded
like the singers of the time so we had
to
cut back on some of the riffs the
melismas the runs and things that
sounded more modern and that sounded
like me and my eclectic taste yeah I
like that and that's cool it shows how
much efforts put into that I like that a
lot and
Tom with Teddy how did you find that
fine line you do so well of being
distant as him but warm at the same time
was that kind of challenging
um it it wasn't challenging because
because I I dug into the two aspects of
the character one in which you're trying
to find the artistic kernel within each
of these people to create this band and
this music but you also realize at the
same time that they are people they're
human beings they have foibles they have
likes they have dislikes so it's up to
the record producers to bring all of the
good stuff forward and and push aside
all of the negative if possible yeah no
I like that that makes complete sense
and yeah I can't wait to see how you
handle Teddy price and then
nabia did you spend a lot of time and
build trust with Riley to prepare for
very you know intimate just relationship
they have being roommate Simone and
Daisy how did that kind of go about when
you worked with Riley it felt very
natural
um we did have some time prior to
connect and yeah she made it easy to
play her best friend oh yeah and it's I
think it's going to be one of those
things that people would love to see
Simone and Daisy on screen together and
they get to see you guys together it's
great and uh Tom was there any producers
or icons in Hollywood that you drew from
for this portrayal of Teddy
yes
um I read Jerry Wesley's book his
biography I read
um Phil spector's biography
um I talked with a man named Al Bell who
ran Stacks records for a long time
um and I drew up on my own experience of
of having a lot of musician friends when
I lived in New York in the 70s oh that's
really cool and I love to hear when you
do prep through Reading I think that's
really cool as an actor and personal
connections as well
um nabia what will you take away the
most in your career from being on a big
show like this like what will you bring
with you as you move on
uh discipline
um presents
and
I'll always take my theater background
with me and my music background as well
oh I love that yeah and you get to see
it now enhanced on Amazon everyone check
out and watch nabia and Tom crush it in
Daisy Jones and six on Prime video today
thank you guys so much for joining me
I'm talking in the future
thank you